لن اترك مشكلات ايران الخارجيه ونتحول الى
الداخل ففي شهرها الثالث تتزايد
الاحتجاجات في مختلف المدن بينما تزيد
السلطات جرعه القمع فتحت قوات الامن
الايرانيه النار على اشخاص في محطه مترو
في العاصمه طهران كما قامت بضرب النساء
النساء اللواتي لم يكن يرتدين اغطيه شعر
الزاميه في المحطه واظهرت لقطات تم
تداولها على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
ركابا يركضون نحو المخارج وسقط الكثيرون
منهم ودهسوا بعد ان فتحت الشرطه النار على
منصه ملتحمه كما صورت لقطه اخرى افرادا من
الشرطه يسيرون داخل عربات المترو ويضربون
النساء بالهراوات في الاونه الاخيره اصبحت
محطات المترو ووسائل النقل العام موقعا
لعنف السلطات ومراقبه المواطنين المحتجين
نظرا لمحدوديه المكان مقارنه تظاهرات التي
تخرج في الشوارع وقبل الاحت كان رئيس ما
تسمى بشرطه الاخلاق قال ان الحكومه تخطط
لاستخدام تقنيه التعرف على الوجوه
لاستهداف النساء غير الملتزمات بالزي
المناسب
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بيزاتك
[موسيقى]
امس كان من اكثر الايام دمويه حيث سقط 15
قتيلا سبعه منهم في مدينه اذاج شمال شرق
مدينه الاحواز من بين القتلى الاحتجاجات
من بين قتله الاحتجاجات بحسب منظمات
حقوقيه طفل في التاسعه من عمره كان يجلس
في السياره رفقه والده عندما اطلقت عليه
قوه البسيج النار
نذكر دائما بانه وافقا لمنظمه حقوق
الانسان الايرانيه قتل اكثر من 300 شخص
على ايدي قوات الامن خلال شهرين
الاحتجاجات بينما اعتقلت السلطات واكثر من
الفا اخرين مؤخرا عمد المحتاجون الى تحصيل
شوارعهم واقامه المتاريس تحسبا للصدام مع
قوه الامن التي زادت من مستوى العنف ضدهم
بشكل كبير
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لكن بينما ينتقد العالم كله الا ان
الايراني اشاد اعضاء في البرلمان به
وصوتوا باغلبيه الساحقه مع العقوبات
القاسيه على المشاركين في الاحتجاجات
والتي قد تصل الى الاعدام اللافت بين
هؤلاء النواب زهره الهيان عضو البرلمان
التي ايدت عقوبه الاعدام وحضت الامم
المتحده على القدوم الى ايران لترى ما
وصفته بالتقدم الذي احرزته المراه
الايرانيه الهيان دعت العالم لعدم تصديق
التقارير الاعلاميه حول ايران
وعددت بعضا من ما اسمتها الانجازات التي
حققتها الحكومه للنساء الايرانيات
وللمفارقه
هيام شاركت برفقه كاظم غريبه بادي وهو
نائب رئيس السلطه القضائيه الايرانيه في
اجتماع للجمعيه العموميه للامم المتحده
وللمفارقه الاكبر اعتمد هذا الاجتماع
قرارا لصالح القضاء على جميع اشكال العنف
ضد النساء والفتيات
[موسيقى]
الاضراب الذي شهدته مختلف المدن الايرانيه
خصوصا في العاصمه طهران دفع مجله نيوز ويك
للمقارنه بين الوضع حاليا والوضع خلال
الايام الاخيره لشاه ايران في السلطه
ورصدت المجله العوامل المشتركه بين
الحدثين وفي مقدمتها اضراب البازار الكبير
في طهران وهو مركز ثقل اقتصادي مهم وكان
يمثل رابطا بين رجال الدين وتجار الطبقه
الوسطى الذين دعموا ثوره
1979 من القرن الماضي المجله اشارت الى ان
المختلف الان هو دوره وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي مع بقاء رمزيه البازار
التاريخيه فوسائل التواصل تتيح للمحتاجين
امكانيه التخطيط والتنظيم وان حاولت سلطات
قطع الانترنت في ايران اشارت يوزويك اخيرا
الى ان نجاح الثوره ضد الشاه كانت لانه لم
يستخدم العنف اما النظام الايراني فيبدو
انه اخذ على نفسه عهدا بان لا يفعل مثل
الشاه وان يستخدم القمع الى اخر مدى
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
رجلا